hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast diabetic cardiomyopathy
modeling and screaming with IPSC
cardiomyocytes I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
cellular dynamics international cellular
dynamics is a leading developer and
producer of fully functioning human
cells in industrial quantities to
precise specifications
CBI's proprietary products encompass
multiple IPS SI derived tissue cell
types that recapitulate native human
biology for more information on standard
by cell and custom micelle products
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green shoe and a
button lower left now like to introduce
today's speakers dr. Robert Nocona is a
senior principal scientist at Roche
Pharma and research development Basel in
the neuroscience of homology and rare
disease DTA he has a medical background
and strong research experience in stem
cell biology he established the sim stem
cell group in the cardiovascular and
metabolic discovery at Roche where
research in his group has been directed
at understanding the pathophysiological
mechanisms and development complications
in the heart using patient specific IPS
sees the patient in a dish paradigm
recently the group is establishing in
vitro disease modeling to identify new
drugs for the retina remodeling
to age-related macular degeneration AMD
his research interest includes the
identification and characterization of
genes that regulate tissue repair and
regeneration aiming to develop
regenerative medicines activating
endogenous tissue progenitors dr. Brad
Swanson is senior director of cell
biology research and development at
cellular dynamics international where he
led the effort to develop the first
commercially available H IPS see dried
cell product I sell cardiomyocytes and
several other H IPS see models including
cortical neurons dopaminergic neurons
skeletal muscle cardiac progenitors and
astrocytes prior to CVI dr. Swanson was
a senior scientist at Roche imogen where
he established among other items the
industry's first sequence capture
product for targeted next generation
sequencing workflows
he started his industry career and
kromega as a senior scientist developing
small molecule high-throughput screening
products dr. Swanson received his PhD in
cellular and molecular biology cardiac
differentiation from UW Madison
undertook postdoctoral research in T
cell behavior at the National Jewish
Medical Center H HTM I in Denver
Colorado and joined Columbus Children's
Research Institute Ohio State University
Center for vaccines and immunity as an
assistant professor I will now turn it
over to dr. Swanson for his presentation
okay first I'd like to thank everyone
for making time to participate in our
webinar today I'm pleased to provide
both the short introduction touching on
CD ice technical capabilities in the
IPSC space and some brief examples of
disease modeling the Bloor were enabled
by our products after this introduction
will then hear Roberto's fascinating
presentation on diabetic cardiomyopathy
modeling with IPS you derive
cardiomyocytes
the agenda for the webinar is as follows
first will briefly cover CVS product
offerings and technological capabilities
to enable IPSC disease modeling
following that introduction and will
highlight disease modeling case studies
in cardiac hypertrophy Alzheimer's
disease in epilepsy where IPS see models
from CDI were used after that Roberta
will take over and describe a studies
I'm diabetic cardiomyopathy using IPS
c-drive cardiomyocytes deriving IPS ES
and differentiated cells from our PSCs
with a consistent high degree of quality
is not a simple task as many of you may
know this slide outlines the four
critical areas of stem cell expertise
CBI has spent years developing to enable
delivery of human IPC IPSC drug products
to our customers these four critical
areas are IPS see derivation genome
engineering differentiation methodology
development and large-scale manufacturer
expertise in all these barriers are
required in order for any company to
provide robust IPSC drive products to
their customers the discovery of IPS C
is enabled a new era of personalized
biology which is being used to advance
general and personalized medicine
discoveries both in the drug discovery
and cell therapy taxpayers to deliver
products that enable rapid and robust
advances in these areas providers of IPs
seen throughout biological systems must
meet the following requirements number
one is a reproducible derivation of IPS
CS from any donor ideally in a parallel
fashion number two the ability to
efficiently modify the genome of our
PSCs to fix earned these mutations of
interest or create building assays
number three consistent manufacturer of
sufficient quantities of differentiated
cells to support large-scale experiments
such as small molecule library screening
number four perform the first three
points to tight specifications under a
quality management system we pride
ourselves at CDI delivering and all four
of these points when developing and
manufacturing our stem cell products
over the past six years or so CDI is
commercialized nearly a dozen human iPS
seen drive cell types which are listed
on this slide in chronological order
and these represent a large range of
biological areas areas such as
cardiovascular biology with the ISO
cardiomyocytes and a recently launched
ISIL cardio myocyte squared products iso
cardiac progenitor cells and isil
endothelial cells another area of
significant focus is the neuroscience
space with ISIL neurons
I saw broken neurons and I saw
astrocytes we also offer our muscle
custom products which allow the customer
at lab PLC's reprogrammed genome
engineering performed and differentiated
cells made from their own vulnerable
donors focus of today's webinar is
disease modeling with IPS see drive
cells now there are a number of
strategies that can be employed to model
disease Lascelles differentiated from
IPS sees most of these strategies can be
lumped into three categories innate
induced and engineered disease modeling
innate modeling entails comparing the
function or phenotype of cells from a
normal donor but those from donor with a
genetically linked disease such as
Parkinson's disease in the case of
dopaminergic neurons induced disease
modeling involves culturing
differentiated cells from a normal
daughter in healthy and disease inducing
conditions to study the difference in
their function and phenotype the recent
development of several gene editing
tools has opened a whole world of
possibilities with engineered disease
modeling one can take normal daughter
IPS ES and create mutations of interest
and then compare the differentiated
cells from the normal donor from the
engineered isogenic controls the verse
can be performed as well where one fix
is a known mutation of interest in IPS
sees from a diseased donor and then
compares differentiated cells from the
gene corrected an original disease donor
IPS sees using this methodology and drug
screening allows for what I like to call
target based phenotypic screening one
can have the benefits of studying a
known target but also have the added
benefit of performing that study in the
rich biological context of a
differentiated human cell probing or
quantifying that rich biological context
can be performed with all are the
typical analytical methods such as flow
cytometry functional drug responses with
cell based assays gene expression
studies high content imaging collector
physiological measurements etc
the amount of published data
demonstrating proof of concept of
disease modeling and IPS ease is growing
rapidly this slide highlights just some
of the wide range of disease areas where
IPS see the disease modeling has been
successful I'll focus on the cardiac and
neuroscience areas for the remainder of
the introduction in the next part of the
talk I'll briefly describe three
examples of CDA I sell products being
used in disease modeling starting first
with cardiac hypertrophy first some
background on CDI is ISIL cardiomyocytes
they were the first truly commercialized
human iPS he derived product on the
market having been available since 2009
they're provided as a crop reserve
greater than 95% pure population of
cardiomyocytes these cells are in use in
19 in the top 20 Pharma and our
foundation for over 40 publications to
date each route comes with sufficient
cells to play an entire 96-well plate as
well of medium sufficient for culture
for up to two weeks the phenotype and
function of ISIL cardi mines Maya sites
have been extensively studied in the key
areas of cardio myocyte biology
including metabolism electrophysiology
and these cells are gaining significant
adoption as a standard cell model to
investigate cardiac toxicity studies
comparing cardiac gene expression
multiple sources of primary
cardiomyocytes versus I saw
cardiomyocytes demonstrate that ISIL
cardiomyocytes have a gene expression
profile much closer to negative heart
tissue then do isolated primary
cardiomyocytes studies of energy
metabolism and biochemistry demonstrate
the cardiomyocytes exhibit robust
mitochondrial respiration and have the
signal transduction pathways one expects
and a fully functional human party my
assay the Heath is and contractile
properties of these cells are also well
understood and documented in the
literature the next few slides summarize
work performed at CDI to demonstrate
that SLE cardiomyocytes robustly
recapitulate a hypertrophic response in
vitro the top panel in the slide
illustrates what happens to the heart
and cardiomyocytes in particular when
encountering a pathological hypertrophic
stimulus such as increased levels of
endothelium long this response is
characterized by increased party myocyte
size and protein synthesis and a
reversion to a more fetal gene
expression program
particularly one can measure induction
brain naturally protein and atrial
natriuretic protein in response to a
hypertrophic stimulus a straightforward
culturing and treatment of ISIL
cardiomyocytes with a hypertrophic
inducer such as endothelin lon
illustrated on the bottom of the slide
facilitates the study of this biological
response
this next slide demonstrates that I saw
cardiomyocytes treated with in 2001 to
induce a hypertrophic response
upregulate BMP expression as a read up
for the hypertrophy this mode of disease
modeling would fall under what we call
induced disease modeling as you're
treating whether there are normally
healthy cells with the disease inducing
stimulus to induce the disease phenotype
this induction is robust and easily
easily quantifiable using qrt-pcr for
gene expression and high content imaging
Eliza and flow cytometry to look at
protein expression each of these
analytical methods has a wide dynamic
range and highly reproducible technical
replicates as demonstrated by the the
high Z prime values for the high content
imaging acid the EC fifties also have
tight concordance across quantitation
methodologies there have been multiple
publications using this model system to
study mechanisms of cardiac hypertrophy
now CDI is participating in a
large-scale collaborative project funded
by the NHLBI to study the hypertrophic
response of party Maya sites
manufactured from IPS es from a 250
dollar panel selected from the hyper gen
cohort which is a population of
african-americans known to have
hypertension Jia studies have been
performed on this group of individuals
to study genetic risk factors of
hypertension CDI is enabling this
technology this study by deriving IPS ES
and pure human cardiomyocytes from each
of these 250 individuals which will then
be studied for their response to the
hypertrophic stimuli in vitro this
studying disease modeling is a
large-scale example of a named disease
modeling and that we are studying how
the genetic makeup of the donors in the
cohort influences the phenotype in the
function of their cardiomyocytes
differentiated from the IPS CS c has
unique unique capabilities in parallel
manufacturing of both IPS ES and
differentiated cells make large-scale
disease
modeling studies like these possible for
the remainder of my talk from up the
remainder of the introduction I will
focus on disease modeling in the
neuroscience space in particular
modeling Alzheimer's disease and
epilepsy the last two examples of
disease modeling in today's introduction
both user Ison neuron product
these cells are terminally
differentiated cortical neurons that
exhibit a forebrain phenotype an
examining gene expression of regional
central nervous system markers a
particular note has shown in the bar
graph a hile of these cells have a high
level of Fox g1 expression the exhibit
immature neuronal fina morphology and
phenotype has visualized through immuno
standing for beta 3 tubulin and map two
proteins they're a mixture of inhibitory
GABAergic and excitatory glutamatergic
neurons with the population having a
slightly higher proportion of inhibitory
GABAergic neurons a neuroscience
colleagues from GSK developed and
published a nice model system to study
Alzheimer's disease mechanisms and I saw
neurons using induced disease modeling
they demonstrated a dose-dependent toxic
effect and I saw neurons in response to
amyloid beta peptide which is known to
play a role in the loss of neurons in
Alzheimer's disease this toxic effect
was measurable book by Lawson saw
viability measured by salt Idaho and in
reduction in average narek lengths using
this model system they successfully
identified a number of hits in a small
molecule library screen that protected
the I saw neurons from the toxic effect
of the hammer a beta peptide follow up
mechanistic studies help identify the
cdk2 is a target of one of the two
screens hits identifying what a unique
pathway in which and when beta protein
exhibits its toxic effects to neurons
the last example of disease modeling is
a case of engineered disease modeling
that enabled the study the cellular
study of epilepsy in vitro and the study
focuses on the sodium activated
potassium channel KCM t1 which regulates
neuronal excitability and determines how
neuron
respond to repeated high-frequency
stimulation which is really what happens
during an epileptic episode this ion
channel has been shown to have a role
and talk both cognitive defects and
early onset childhood epilepsy s the
genome engineering group here at CDI
engineered a gain of function mutation
in the case ent one channel at the P 924
l locus our amino acid and they
engineered this in a normal donor IPSC
line and after we did the engineering
steps they differentiated a cortical
neuron similar to the ice on our own
product from both the engineered and the
uh ninja neared lines and tested these
neurons for synchronous electrical
activity and culture on a multi
electrode array instrument the left half
of this slide shows 48 well plate from
the actual and Biosystems maestro mea
instrument each of the walls on that
plate contain a four by four grid of
electrodes that measure single unit
recording basically the electrical
activity of the cells cultured on top of
them the raw data recordings shown in
the lower left of the slide demonstrates
an example of synchronous bursting
activity within one wall or burst of
electrical activity is seen at the same
time across the majority of the
electrodes in the law many quantitative
parameters can be extracted from this
type of raw data and the right side of
the slide touches on three parameters of
importance for this model system the bar
graphs and white demonstrate that the
number of bursts per minute in wild-type
and k cnt1 gain-of-function mutant
neurons are not statistically different
however the intensity within those
bursts are much higher in the mutant
neurons and compared to the wild type
neurons and this mimics the epileptic
phenotype in vivo this increasing
intensity leads to a higher degree of
synchronous activity and the
gain-of-function mutant neuron culture
is shown in the bottom bar graph and
then took include you can see
demonstrated that this increased
synchronicity can be attenuated with
treatment by partial k cnt1 hagnes
quinidine in a dose-dependent fashion
and with that last data slide i'd like
to now turn the presentation over to
roberto for his presentation
on modeling diabetic cardiomyopathy with
IPS he throughout cardiomyocytes
Thank You Brad thank you everybody for
attending the webinar on my side as well
and I today I would like to actually
give you like an assemble how we use the
IPS technology and in particularly IPS
there are cardiomyocytes for the system
for modeling genetic abnormality and in
particularly I refer to the patient in a
dish approach that we'll use in period
in in Basel and so before we start I
like to point that there are different
ways to use stem cell in drug discovery
the first pillar on the left is as a
tool listen now the patient IPS becomes
an unlimited source of humans or money
cells that are used for the patient in
an ich approach for the in vitro disease
modeling then there is a second pillar
that is the target where now we try to
develop small molecules to specifically
activate our adult somatic stem cells
that are in our tissue and this is
referred like chemical change in
medicine and then is the last one that
is the certainty where now we inject
cells to repair regenerate the organ and
tissue in particularly in my group we
rush we don't work on the on the cervix
or thoroughly and we are just few
approaching a chemical returning
medicine and today we will focus
specifically on the use of stem cell
mass as a tool of world
this is modeling and so I will try to
introduce you a bit the problem in
particularly highlighting the link
between the inception and the heart
complication then we go to the mall
the IPS they're armed cardiomyocytes
model that we use for drug discovery and
then hopefully we have some conclusion
and some vision for the future so let's
start with the big statue this is
clearly an unmet medical need as it's
becoming epidemic in fact by 2030 we
will have almost like off billions
patient worldwide and this number is
increasing day by day
and the big problem is actually not that
the patient did why for the IPL Kristina
but more for the stress that this
diabetic macro environment is triggering
in different organ and tissue and in
particularly in the cardiovascular
system and on the heart just to frame
how relevant is the myocardial
complication of diabetes you can for
example you can imagine and naturally is
reality that in in the United States
hospitals for example one out of the
three patient that are admitted in
emergency for our trainer they will be
genetic so there is a huge prevalence of
in the body population of our video and
we know that this is actually almost
like a primary condition that is called
the American democracy where there is a
distinct primary part of physiology in
the condom outside of these patients and
on these slides I like to point to use
some important aspect of the part of
physiology of these disease you can see
on the left for example postmortem
samples of cardiomyocytes from wealthy
patients
cardiomyocytes a very nice online it and
there is no iPod to fill in the cells
instead if you take for example a post
mortem samples from a patient with your
medical team already you can immediately
see on the right the research these are
really of the sarcomeric structure of
cardiomyocytes they are completely
scattered and if you look on on down you
see as well that the the cell sites is
much bigger and it's really like an
birth of love the cells so these
important points are important to keep
in mind because I will try them to
translate some of this phenotype in our
individual approach and so this is
actually a bit what we try to do is to
somehow resemble these diabetic stress
in vitro on human cardiomyocytes and
then look if we can modify with drugs
some of this molecular and cellular
mechanism that leads to the disarray of
the cardiomyocytes and to the future of
the diabetic animal body and of course
made is important to say why we want to
do that in in a pharmaceutical drug
discovery approach and why it's
important to do that and know here in
these slides I refer to a nice review
from our collective AstraZeneca where
actually they evaluated small molecules
the small modest portfolio during the
2005 and 2010 and they somehow
retrospectively try to understand why
they were like failure in the clinical
in a clinical phase and you can see in
the face should be we had something like
they had on some like 88 compounds
failing for efficacy and now if you like
take this 88 compounds and you try to
understand what is the reason for this
failure actually there is one of the
main reason was really the lost and not
the big link between the target and and
and modest that they were using so we
learn and I learned a lot from this
review and so the key learning actually
in fact that there is a strong link
between we need to have a very strong
link between a target or the pathway and
our disease and we need to somehow bring
the human part of physiology at the
preclinical drug discovery know that
- maybe achieve a better translation in
the definitely so in this spirit in mind
we try to give it now an assemble I'll
reduce in the patient IPS in the
diabetic animal body so first of all
they were already a lot of people
working on this particular complication
and this mechanism and because it's very
hard at work primary human
cardiomyocytes because of course we need
a post-mortem access to the heart of the
patient a lot of people were using in
using a condom our sites we know that
these cardiomyocytes respond differently
to diabetic stressor and they have as
well a different pathway and response
and the other big problem is that the
newer models cannot account for the
human genetic variation so now the IPS
keep the dweller
bandage that you can indeed the adding
for some human genetic I mean human IPS
there are answers and you derive your
cardiomyocytes and then you try to mimic
the stressor that we know very well in
the clinics and so with this in mind we
try to search for human condom assets
that could be utilized in a
pharmaceutical setup so in big amounts
and at that point we got in contact with
CDI and we actually evaluated their IPS
there are cardiomyocytes and in Portugal
to see them they had a very and go to
the producible characteristic of the RP
Adamas at the head of all the features
that were really highlighted by Brad and
the only things we needed to maybe to
find him for our approach was to induce
maybe a more mature phenotype
indeed you know it's possible to
manipulate the metabolism of the ideas
that are the muscles to use a more
mature phenotype and we actually still
at some trick from nature in fact during
our federal life
the cardiomyocytes will use mostly
glycolysis for energy production and
then as soon we are born they will
switch instead the two fatty acid that's
a better bet oxidation for energy source
so with this amount with this in mind
that we try to do exactly the same we
play the cells in the normal medium we
let them attach for two days and then
add eight zero we now culture them with
a maturation medium that is completely
glucose free is completely chemically
defined and then says energy source
effect the acid so we forced the cells
to become and to go in better and better
as that oxidation and eventually to
mature of course we needed to convince
ourself that indeed we have been more
mature a phenotype and not needed to
convince us well our reviewers in the
paper that was published recently in
cell reports and we use it for these two
parameters that are very well described
in this review from trans memory the
first parameter is actually the
sarcomere length and the sarcomere
organization so for example if you look
at the circulars in a fact in with an
effect in streaming you will see very
nicely striation with stripes in the
indica demo sites and the other one is
instead a parameter in the
electrophysiology we know that for
example kardama sites when is more
mature will have an increase in the
cotton sodium currency and this will
increase the the duration of the action
potential and the upstroke velocity so
we took all this parameter we started to
ask do we indeed after this maturation
step in useless reach these parameters
and for the sarcomeric organization with
indeed confirm that after three days in
moderation medium and forcing the
cardiomyocytes in bed oxidation we could
have an increase of the cartomizer score
that actually reads the striation in
effect in in channel as you can see in
this picture and as well we could show
that there is an increase in the
sacrament length as shown by the the
reviewer and my other papers before and
this translates well to an increase of
key genes that are more espresso ducted
the three days of modulation medium so
the next part was indeed to confirm the
electrophysiology and the sodium
currency so for the sodium current
density we use a bottle to die for the
sodium we could see indeed that there is
an increase of the up stroke velocity
and also the absolute velocity here and
as well of the duration of the action
potential this was a swirl worried well
confirmed by the expression of gene
expression of some p sodium sodium
channel and that was and this is the
final true by patch clamp we could see
indeed that there is in red after the
three days in increase in the sodium
currency and even if it's not
statistically significant but we could
see that there is higher conductance for
the sodium currency so with this we were
very well convinced that we at least we
could have a more mature phenotype of
the cardiomyocytes and then we went to
the second step that is actually the
mimicking of their very stressful in
vitro so for disregards now after the
three days in moderation medium then we
switch to a medium that as some of the
key they are very stressed so that I
reported in
in particular high glucose we know very
well their businesses where he will
describe Iracema
of course increase of insulin increase
of fatty acid and some noodles some
almonds like the cortisone and the total
in one that indeed are hiring the in the
plasma patient with a medic on your body
so when we expose the SAS to the beta
stress so we could observe different
phenotypes so the first one is secretion
of the BMP biomarker in the cellular
medium to very high quantities which one
the picogram per ml and I like to point
here that indeed for someone you recruit
in clinical trials for a heart failure
one of the inclusion criteria is I mean
the plasma can be higher than 150 180
and are very important we could see that
after these 48 hours in the bitty stress
so we could see a reorganization of the
sarcomeric structure and increase of
hypertrophy at the cellular level and
the nuclear later and very important
that the structural is this organization
was connected to a decrease in the
concentration the meaning that there is
a correlation between with the
structural cellular organization and the
calcium transient not only we could see
this but we could see as well a
different phenotype of the diabetic
structure structural remodeling for
example lipid accumulation with the name
red assay and oxidative stress live in
the peroxidation with a specific dye
once we did this to be really sure that
you know what we see in the dish is
somehow resembling what is happening in
the country on all sides of this patient
affected by the genetic complication we
gave some of the samples to one of our
collaborator professor raining the
standard at the University of Basel
we perform an electron microscopy we
could see that for example with
cardiomyocytes in moderation medium has
a nice motivation of the sarcomeric
structure in bacteria you can see the
red line here and now if you indeed
culture the cardiomyocytes under the
embedded stress you see a completely
disarray as captured the morphology of
the sacramental structure and you can
start to see these dead bodies so these
dead bodies are very important for the
characterization of the model because
they've been already described in mouse
models of art failure like you know the
teamollie knockdown well you can see
this formation of the dead body and more
importantly in post-mortem samples with
the patient affected by the very car
demography so with this we were really
completed in our in vitro you know
surrogate was resembled some aspect of
the clinical features of this patient
and we could really identify three major
parameters that we wanted to follow in
our later on drug discovery approach the
BMP release in the medium the
hypertrophy as cell and nuclear area and
the sarcomeric disorganisation
so now the next step is to trust ladies
endpoints in affinity big drug discovery
approach before doing that we try to
understand a bit what's going on at the
level of the of the pathway and in the
genes and to do this we perform at the
genomic analysis where we compared the
kardama sites under motivation medium
and the cardiomyocytes under a very
stressed or we could see for example
that opponent they're very very stressor
we can activate in red
pathway that are in
correlated with the glucose metabolism
and the Krebs cycle so showing that
indeed the cells were growing back in a
sort of glycolic see and very important
we could see down regulation of pathway
for assembly in the province translation
in unfolded protein response so very
interesting now what you can do and you
can see this data that are publishing
you can go in one for example of these
dots and retrieve all the genes that are
up and down regulating this particular
pathway now adding these lists of genes
you can see if there are any publicly
available library or rush library
compounds that her and in the small
models that are annotated versus these
particular genes so we did this import
even with the publicly available library
and we could then assemble a library
that could be tested in our family be
screening approach with our IPS there I
met cardiomyocytes and the screen is
actually performing that the cells are
lipid for three days in moderation
medium and then add a tree we now apply
the compound and be a very stressor at
the same time and we read after 48 hours
incubation very importantly that for
ritual we recorded the three end points
so the cardiomyocytes called
so the organization of moussaka MERS the
BMP release in the middle and the
nuclear and the attract trophy and you
can see that in in all three parameter
we could see a recent increase of the
signal and based on the fact that we
have seen in this genomic analysis that
we have seen up regulation of the total
impact way and on the cortisol pathway
we decided to use as positive control a
combination or belief every storm and
Besant on pasanda is and total in one
inhibitory evolution is a cortical
inhibitor and indeed in all our plates
you know our screening this combination
this positive control could rest abla SH
all our hand points as C healing in the
orange an orange bar so based on this we
then perform at the full palette screen
with the 480 compounds where we have
associated very nice annotation on the
target so you can imagine that this is a
sort of a chemical biology approach and
out over for under eighty we could
indeed identify the forty seven eighths
then as you will do in any screening
campaign so we confirm at least it's
with a dose response and you can see
that we have a different compounds
eating different pathway for example
lots of compounds were modulating the
cuts in signaling other word kinase
inhibitor harder were modeling in the
protein translation and foreign
processing control the end of course
these were selected based on our genomic
analysis and we had very good results in
particularly in compound modulating the
cultural signaling and some kinase
individual multi kinase inhibitor and as
well compound modulating
the protein translation and protein
processing so now what is very
fascinating that different compound with
different model action can indeed in a
dose-response revert these endpoints
that we addressed with our screaming
campaign so the next part was really to
see if any of these aids could indeed as
well induce some or revert some function
and end points and for example before we
look at the limit accumulation and
peroxidation you can see that some
costume cuts modulating light whose peel
and can indeed decrease the lipid
accumulation and tennis well decrease in
the peroxidation even if the mode of
action is completely unrelated to
peroxide peroxidation and lipid
accumulation and very interesting the
foursome of compound that are involving
for example protein translation can
restore for example the consumer
transient they are destructed by the
very structure so now this is actually
opening a completely new chapter for us
because we want to understand at the
molecular level or this compound not
doing so how do they change the
molecular and the pathway context of the
cells and in particularly why compounded
are eating different targets can induce
the same phenotype like for example you
know compound that they
you know motivate the classroom
signaling and compounded for summer
model independent translation but this
is working on going and you know we will
hopefully report something in during
this year or next year the next part
that of the talk is really now focusing
on exploring at best we know the IPS
technology and in particularly to try to
merge in beach with the environmental
driven stress that we did with the beta
stress and genetic background of the
patient so the ability the built-up shoe
has a very true genius genetics and even
margin the telo-genesis the the genetics
of the medical demo body so we could not
identify the single genes with the high
penetrance and for this we tried to have
a more lengthy an empiric approach where
we selected the patient with the extreme
phenotype so what you will see in the
clinics for example the fast progress
reparation adding a bit statue and
professing extremely fast to benefit the
more body or cardiovascular disease or
on the other hand another patient that
this is called at this local vessel so
vision that is immediately statue
science many years but is not having any
clinical symptoms of the cardiovascular
complication so and we dis approach we
together with our khalid IBN GH in
boston we selected out of different
ation to a stimulation one in blue that
is the debate attempt to slow professor
that for example despite the fact that
as having the restructure more than 15
years having a family history of
diabetes had no sign of CVD and on the
other hand we have the red patient that
is the
the bureaucracy so it's actually patient
and in district 2 less than 10 years but
having a strong penetrance and a
clinical document that the
cardiovascular disease phenotype of
course the advantage of this model is
that we can later on compare the medical
history trauma in vitro phenotype but
the key disadvantage is that we are
dealing with extremely more number of
patients or these needs of course
offender confirmation so now the big
advantage that once we obtain the IPS
then islet cells from this patient we
could send the IPS to our colleagues in
Wisconsin at CGI and with the exact same
protocol they difference in the kardama
sites as we use it before in our
standard the cell line to establish our
protocols and once we obtain an
atrocious IPS there are cardiomyocytes
from this patient we had a big surprise
actually even without any the baby
strikes what the baseline just in a
moderation menu we could see that the
debated patient is Robo wrestling first
professors had been less organized
structuring in the South America
structure and we could see as well a
difference between his role profession
and the fast progression in fact at
baseline without time in the very stress
the fast progress of resembling read had
already a reduction in the console
console transient
frequency and some work that was done
even at wisconsi
from CDI you could see that this patient
had the more in regularity in the
bitrate using the impedance readout with
the exchanges so this was extremely you
know a fascinating of course now we
don't know what would I be clear the
reason of these defense and we believe
that there is something at the
level but we don't know yet what it is
not only we will see this phenotype but
we have seen as well a difference
between slow progress and fast progress
in terms of lipid accumulation and
oxidative stress the last part and you
know is of course to see if some of the
compound that we identified could be
reversed some of this phenotype I like
to stress that again in this me tested
before the compounds without any dabeli
stressor and this is very important to
keep in mind because you can see that
for example already the positive control
so the boss internal my favor stone
could indeed the reverse for example the
cardio muscle scholar that was lower in
this noble gasoline with us professor
for the slow professor
in blue we could even revert completely
the the phenotype equal to the our
standard line and we could revert this
one for the fast progressive but with
the less success so this is a very
important point because first of all
here we don't have any the beta stress
so they are not under cortisol and no
telling one but of course the true
positive control the passant and and my
fabrics on they indeed already work on
this on this cardiomyocytes and later on
we have shown that this particular
patient party will be slow progress and
a fast protester have already a baseline
so without the body stress already
enough regulation of the another limb
pathway of the molecular transcriptomic
level and as well of the Google+ old
pathway and the other bit your
difference again that we can see that
despite discard of ours are there but
the same modulation we have seen again a
different profile in response between
the slope of ester and the fast progress
sure and indeed if now we take for some
hour 18 it's that represent a different
mode of action
we could again confirm the difference in
response between the slow-mo lesson in
the first professor in the slow
professor actually 14 out of 18 can
revert the kendama at sport and in the
first professor just ten out of 18 can
Bertie's showing that the first
progressed earnest again and more
prominent problem in the new liberal at
the cellular level it's interesting to
see that for example the top compound
like cigar genome full speed line are
positive for the slow professor and the
fast professor and the regulates you
know the cuts from signaling in machine
and or they are related with the
cultures engine in machinery and this is
very nice as well with those actually in
different in vitro disease modeling
approach that are published by very good
labs in particular related
cardiomyopathy and hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy
well now the investigator in use the in
vitro phenotype mutating some specific
genes that are associated with this
inherited Cardinal body and you know not
questions but they have seen similar
phenotype that we have seen under the
uppity stress in particularly the the
hypertrophy the sarcomeric this
organization and as well
this regulation of the classroom
signaling and not by chance but for
example some of this fellow that could
be reverted by the use of a channel
Carson blocker like Rob Emil novella
beam and we have found indeed that for
some of who this villain is as well a
modifier on the culture of the cultural
marker so what I want to say that there
is a nice analogy between a you know and
our approach that is in case of portion
of the Mossad under drug under the bed
stress that this environmental driven
and this kind of publication where
instead we have a genetically driven
phenotype
now with this I like to conclude and
deep space maybe for a bit of discussion
so I hope that I were away I was able to
show you that the way we we think about
you know using the IPS technology for
drug discovery and in particular that we
believe that placing the human part of
physiology at the core of our
preclinical drug discovery will have
huge impact in the future in particular
we can maybe early on eliminate toxic
compound that can have some safety
concern in the clinics and we believe as
well this approach can have a huge
impact on on on betting on drugs and
eventually new drugs that will have a
better efficacy in in the clinical trial
so circumventing some of the problems
that I highlighted will try to
highlighted with the review from our
AstraZeneca colleagues of course you
know this process needs to be proven is
not yet so we don't get a drug in the
clinics that was discovered with this
approach but it's definitely a space
that needs to be
watch it very carefully because as
breadless well show you its users in
different fields and by different people
in inside so I had my big oath that will
bring the more top results and with this
I need to acknowledge all the people
that worked on this particular project
in particularly Faye and Stefan all that
were true prospects in my group they did
incredible work and Dennis word from my
group Fred and Jack that started a lot
of this approach in the lab Benjamin for
the electrophysiology and validation of
the cells Chara for our discussion and a
lot of advice on how to perform this dis
approach and the team of louder Lara and
Colin Garrett rush that analyzed a lot
of this genomic data very important to
say that we had the fantastic
collaboration with people a CGI after
Kyle Blake called me Ana CEOs we work
very close to them even sometimes they
perform and experiments with us was
great I already mentioned anyone
Alexandra for the electron microscopy
and then I like to conclude knowledge in
the people in Boston in damage that were
generating the IPS lines and with this I
conclude and I'm very happy to take you
on your question thank you thank you
city thank you for the informative
presentations before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green un a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can
our first question is
let's see this question is for dr.
Swanson can I sell cardiomyocytes be
used for patch-clamp studies
specifically sodium ion channel analyses
yes so I'm as Roberto pointed out in
some of the slides you can use ISO
cardiomyocytes for most analyses of the
main ion channels active and calm human
cardiomyocytes sodium potassium calcium
and the various variants of those
channels so this these methodologies
have been well worked out and well
published and very well studied not only
in normal cardiomyocytes but in diseased
patients as well another question for
dr. Swanson do you perform custom
mutagenesis on genes of interest in the
IPS CCM
so yes we do we perform mutagenesis
actually i PSCs is part of our my style
services and we use it either Crispin
crispers or tailings tell employees is
to facilitate Gino genome editing or
genome modification and then we'll go
ahead and differentiate those cells with
the modified genomes into the cell type
of interest so that is one of the
services that we offer in our myself
product line this question is for dr. is
for dr. Alcona can you comment on the
drugs and their pathways that work with
SP but not FP answer could you repeat
the question sorry I I cannot hear
yes of course
can you comment on the drugs and their
pathways that worked with SP but not SP
yes so we are it's a very good question
and at the moment we don't have the
final last word what I can say that
modulating the constant signaling seems
to be a very powerful approach both with
smoke with this low progesterone and the
fast progress sir it seems that the fast
progression is a very somehow very very
hard patient to treat and now what is
very interesting is to see if actually
in both a small local restaurant and
fast professor if the addition of the
compound is indeed in using the same
molecular signature and this is what we
are doing with other college Sierra
thrush but that moment we don't have yet
you know EMS words another approach that
it's very interesting and we try to do
is for example
overexpressed the circuit room because
this is a an approach that is being
evaluated by different company for gene
therapy and it would be very interesting
is to see if actually such such you know
overexpression can rescue our fast
progressed or phenotype what we don't
have yet this as well
another question for dr. Jana was the
cell lying to cell line heterogeneity
excluded in analyses of diabetic IPSC dr
cardiomyocytes and as the presence of
disease phenotype in diabetic IPSC dr
cardiomyocytes suggests the genetic
origin of the disease yeah so I I don't
know if I understood the question
correctly but I think a body at allergy
nity I think you refer to the fact if we
have just cut them out sites in our
culture and indeed yes so the prevalence
of the culture more than 95% is
cardiomyocytes so we believe that the
effect that we see in the dish is
primary and Sullivan was due to the
cardiomyocytes about the cause of the
reason for this difference between for
example the fast progression a slow
progress turn and the fact that we see
with the patient IPS raiga baseline a
phenotype we believe that is genetically
because we know very well that after
reprogramming we somehow remove
epigenetic or remove partially partially
the epigenetic you know fingerprinting
so we believe that is more genetically
but as a lot of people already show it's
very hard to fish it you know the
genetic cause of this of this pen
disposition because most likely they
were different genes involved and to be
honest we are more focused in the
understanding you know the response of
this
patient IPS to to the drugs in order to
somehow evaluate some new telepathic
targets another question for dr. Nocona
regarding diabetic CM phenotype it seems
that the patient specific phenotype is
intrinsic to CM not dependent on a
diabetic new year while in normal IPS
CCM it is the diabetic milieu that
induces phenotype in other words does
this mean that the diabetic camellia in
vivo does not contribute to cv phenotype
yeah I think it's so first of all I mean
the two things are connected because as
maybe I just quickly refer to these but
when we analyze the when we perform
genomic analysis of these patient IDs
cardiomyocytes we could see that indeed
they had this regulation in the dopamine
pathway and in particular pathway so and
we didn't know this before you know so
there is a connection and I think you
know like every disease is not like we
cannot say it's completely genetically
also completely diabetic it is
completely environmental driven but it's
always a combination of the truth so
most likely this patient they have a
transposition you know to genetic
predisposition to overreact to the
diabetic stressor and these together in
use the phenotype so I think it's very
we cannot you know really frame the
genetics or the
environment but it's always a
combination on the two and I think our
approach even if with a small number of
patient is really - I like that with the
patient IPS you can do this kind of
approach you can have a genetic
predisposition with you when you know
that you bring with the patient IPS and
on top you somehow investigate the
response to the clinical environment
that can be for them in this case and
diabetic stress this question is for dr.
Fiona how would one move from a hit in a
phenotypic screening to identifying a
target is this necessary for further
drug development yeah okay this is maybe
it's a guy from Pharma because this is a
very good question so honestly there is
not so no one to the FDA will not
require you to show the the target for
your compound they would just ask you to
show that the new drug works but in
reality you know for the development of
these new potential drugs it's very
important to know the target because you
can work better for them if you see some
safety related issue or if you want to
understand better which is the Terra
Preta kleenex and so far now all to find
this target after a phenotypic approach
is very challenging and we try different
approach for different project and in
reality it's very hard for the single
gene you have you know utilize a
different methodology for some
transcriptomics proteomics
binding of the small values to a protein
you will have always a different list of
genes and this is very you know it's
very informative but it's clearly that
you usually don't get a single target so
this is a bit the challenge that you get
you know when you go infinity betrayal
discovery but this is as well at the
advantage because you know you want to
go for some more and more complex effect
so honestly I don't have the final
answer to this question but I think that
it's important to to have a like a
balance in your portfolio between
phenotypic drug discovery approach and
target based approach because it's
clearly shown that you know some great
drugs comes from a premie target based
approach and some they come from the
phenotypic approach and if you have like
at least an idea of the pathway that you
modulate is very important for clinical
development this question is for dr.
Swanson have either of your
organization's done any disease modeling
in 3d so I'm aware of a number of
customers or collaborators that have
cultured are cardiomyocytes in art I
sell cardiomyocytes as well as
hepatocyte for separate reasons in 3d
culture systems just to study how that
changes the biological response to
compounds etc so yes I'm aware we're not
doing it actively internally very much
but we know a number of our customers as
well as some other collaborators are
studying the biology of a number of our
cell types in 3d culture
I would like to thank our sponsor
cellular dynamics international for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
October 2016 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to for that announcements
your colleagues serve a miss today's
live event see you next time goodbye